what's up bernard
what's up atlas
meeting for the first time in this
lifetime
yep
how you doing
so good
i'm so excited that
so excited that you found uh
you found what we were up to and you
reached out and you're also up to great
things with your mathematical
metaphysics youtube channel and
you wanted to have a conversation
and on earth's awakening
and so
i'm pumped bro
absolutely man i mean
earth's awakening it's happening right
now
and it's been happening
so
it seems like let's help out
yeah like we've been saying ignite
the word we've been using is ignite
with the mission
igniting global awakening igniting it
yeah so igniting meaning like catalysts
so
yeah so we're catalyzing it and so you
do that through things like this content
and people watch that content and then
they go oh what is
earth's awakening what is my true nature
and
um how do i empty myself of
self-interest and how do i purely serve
my other selves and
that's really at the core of it at the
heart of it and so we'll we'll play in
all these different
uh types of of ways of pointing
basically at at it and then um
hopefully it'll serve
in as those catalysts
exactly and i mean i think the earth is
experiencing a major
catalyst
the pandemic being just one of them
there are many catalysts on many levels
and
i love
ignition i think of nucleation as well
because it
since i do work in a school it's a bit
of a slower process
right um
the ignition can
happen
when i mean that's the beauty actually
the the ignition sometimes can happen
instantaneously
um
and actually i'd like to ask you
when did you
awaken at one d and i you might consider
that to be a series of events you might
not consider to be one major moment
but i'm just curious
nice
yeah for me it started with a desire for
truth
and wanting that more than anything
the last 10 years
and just
um always perpetually knowing that there
was more to discover about life there
was a deeper meaning to who we were and
why we were here and that
it was nowhere in the standard cultural
dialogue which was also super confusing
um
yeah
and so then you had to dig and i had to
dig and dig and so i dug through things
like entrepreneurship um i dug through
things like science and then i dug
through spirituality
and i ended up synthesizing and
distilling basically the core wisdoms
from those disciplines um into what
ended up being sort of these moments of
holy [ __ ] like satori experiences um
these realizations that are totally
irreversible
um and yeah there there were several
moments
um
yeah one uh specifically last year
um around this time
um
so the end of 2020 and
[Music]
yeah i remember
um
it was uh
it was an um
a sufi metaphysic that goes
and it means uh the unity of all being
or um
and
when
when initially i was um
looking at that i was feeling like hmm
it sort of aligns with things like uh
tatvam asi uh you are that um i and my
father are one
um
john 10 30.
um and
for me
um it wasn't that special
it was like just knowing concepts across
the different mystic lineages
and knowing it intellectually okay we're
all one we're all one i see i get it i
get it uh blah blah
and then um william chidik wrote a piece
in the uh ibn rabi society on the sufi
metaphysic
and i had never seen um the nuance of
this before
and
he said that um
in the phrase
means less of the unity of all being and
more so the unity of all finding
and when i read that i went into quite
an intense
nervous system shock because i finally
grocked at a more heart level at a more
gut level
who i am
what is i
um
because when you think about it in terms
of the unity of all finding you sort of
recognize that oh it is the one through
all of these different individuations
finding through the veilless veil
through this veil of forgetting finding
itself in all these different tastes and
flavors and combinations and paths some
people go to retreats some people take
anti-agents some people read books some
people sit with different teachers
all this type of stuff and i did a mix
of all of those things
and i was so blown away by how profound
it was to feel the one
finding itself through all of the
different individuations and all of
their different journeys and so for like
10 minutes i was just like crying in the
fetal position and just
like
holy [ __ ] and then
and then there were several other
distinct like pops um
but basically it was it was a series of
um and and i would say now it's more
about purification than anything else so
right now i would say it's more about
emptiness and more about no self
than anything else
so yeah so in buddhism you get to um
you could say
uh
both shunyata as well as anata so
emptiness as well as um
void as well as
no self and
and initially again you're studying this
a year or two ago and you're like okay
concept concept and then eventually it
actually hits your heart and it hits
your gut because you recognize that what
one means by the path of purification is
it means the emptying of self-interest
and it means
being purely in service to your other
selves so you're always in a sense
available with wisdom and with love
unified together which we'll probably
talk about as well
and that
you're serving without any interest in
um being validated or being seen or
being worthy for that process basically
your cup is always full your sun is
always radiating and then the no self
component meaning that you've recognized
you've seen through the illusion
of that there is no
self
located here
if the lowercase s self or what we refer
to as me or mine or i
perpetually in a localized
body
has been seen through and you recognize
that what you actually are is a formless
infinite intelligence that is
creating endlessly
and that
you are all
you are all and you are so you are
everything and you are no thing you
aren't a thing at the same time because
you're a field it's field recognition
and
and so yeah so i would say those were
sort of the the
that led me up to basically the path of
purification now which is what you could
call doing the work
so now it's about doing the work which
is purifying where you're coming from
doing a [ __ ] load of cleanup so if
you're if your physical space in your
digital space
and your
relationships and your general
administration of life your health and
wellness and your state of being are not
cleaned up which is what we're doing
right now in no limit society with
bentino and onorag if you're if those
things are not cleaned up then they will
show up in the way you express yourself
in a distorted way
and so by clea by doing the cleanup you
purify where you're coming from so that
way you're actually serving life you're
serving life awakening you're serving
earth's awakening
that was beautiful
thanks
brother you made the
the choice as raw calls it
the third density choice which is to
or rather the choice to serve others
as yourself i mean the self disappears
the more and more you serve
is that
what fair to say yeah that's a great way
to put it yeah the lowercase s self
disappears the more you serve and the
capital s self
god slash no self opens
exactly
yeah
the one
the void is also the plenum
right the the
the infinite state is also the empty
state
and combined
we could call that
as frank yang would say the natty state
the natty state baby the natty state
and the idea is to always is to cherish
each experience
right i mean and cherish means not just
let's adore it because if you're in a
car accident
you know are you gonna
it's not quite appropriate to just adore
what's happening so so i suppose that's
i know i loved hearing where you're at i
just want to share where i'm at
yeah of course i
i i guess
also in the purification process and
very much focusing on
when things do go wrong when
there appear to be mistakes or
shortcomings
or distortions that arise
which can't just be shrugged off
something that
happens like a physical illness or a
physical injury
catalyst that has not been properly
mentally processed and now becomes
physical
right and it's something you can't just
will away
right um
that's
that dynamical part of
perfection
where it's we're not just in a perfect
state where everything is
where no action needs to be taken
some
catalyst forces and induces action
and
it's tricky to keep
unity at the forefront when you are
evolving away from a certain state due
to catalyst
does that does that make sense
yes yeah great way to put in another way
to say that is that all is a school
all is a video game that you designed
that's the that's the important thing if
you can grok that at a faster
you can liberate yourself from the
victim mentality and shift to the
creator mentality and recognize that i
designed my own video game for myself my
own school for myself and then i see
catalysts
as things that are not
oh i'm going to be small i'm the victim
of all of these catalysts my
circumstances but rather my state of
being my vibration my frequency itself
is generating my reality and the more
that my state of being itself is more
empty of self-interest and more purely
in service to others more god realized
or capitalist self-realized the more
that my circumstances my reality will
actually mirror that and that they will
be just like
so just mwah
and so yes you're right when you do get
something really difficult as a catalyst
you created it and at that time it's not
meant to be uh everything is absolute
flowers um it's meant to be like there's
gonna be some pain but it's up to you if
that creates suffering or not physical
pain does not equal suffering ever
ever
physical pain itself is horrible i had a
very very bad
a little over a year ago injury on the
left side of my body were
fractured along it
fractured a rib it punctured my lung
deflate all this type of stuff and i
remember just going back like in the car
in severe pain on the way to the
hospital and just the people that were
in the car were just like dude how is
this guy so meditative i was saying
things like your greatest traumas are
your greatest treasures in the car on
the way to the hospital and and it was
just so great because it's all about
your state of being it's all about that
state of being can you see even in the
most intense pain possible rather than
suffering and complaining and whining
that you created it
that it's a catalyst for you and uh yeah
so that that would be my take on it and
it was such a fun direct experience that
i had with that like in september yeah
2020.
yeah knowing that you programmed it
that's the nutty part
right because
locally speaking i mean if you're a
scientifically minded person everything
is localistically evolving right i mean
you're moving things and how can you
control anything that's outside of you
the aura these kinds of things don't
even make sense
in a scientific well but pre-signed
pre-synthesis
right
uh yeah pre-quantitative
really
yeah right i mean you you talk to lingan
so so i mean he's working on
distributing quantum properties over all
of realities so even what we're saying
you know speaking is a quantum
mechanical action
and
i mean
i think the but that's where that's
where things start to ease is where you
start to realize that things are
self-programmed it's just that
you know your higher self and then of
course the highest self the self with
the capital s
is
well that's the question right
there's pre-incarnation programming as
well i mean let's say that you are you
know your two parents
and all of a sudden your child is born
with
a form of cerebral palsy
i'm wondering what your take on
pre-incarnation programming
is with respect to
genetic genetic deformities degenerative
diseases
even genetic predispositions i mean are
you do you actively think about this
not actively but this is a
very cool question and it
um
it it kind of plays into the color
palette a lot um in terms of you know
the ones not going to solely incarnate
with um no
birth difficulties birth deficiencies um
and it so you know everything's in an
entangled state so meaning that as
you call
a birth deficiency
it's also a birth gift or a birth
experience in a sense um so you you made
an agreement to incarnate
on behalf of the one
so you could have the experience of what
it's like to have
own hearing in only one ear you know one
of my friends here has that issue and
he and this is a thing like
it sucks of course but it's also like
something like wow i'm having this
experience that i created on behalf of
the one and that
there's even worse scenarios than that
like you were describing like horrible
neurodegeneration um things like people
dying when they're just a kid
this type of stuff um
and
you know it's you you know that's
another thing it's you it's this
boundless energy that's doing that
and that wants to experience that wants
to learn from that
but at the same time you're having these
incredible scientific advancements like
being able to reprogram dna using
technologies like crispr and whatnot
where for example you can eradicate
genetic mutations that cause um horrible
diseases upon birth so
um we're we're really you know we're
activating a lot of god-like potential
which is fat which is fantastic um but
we do
simultaneously need to awaken our
consciousness to be able to understand
the unity underneath of everything so
that we don't create any malevolences
along the way um with these godlike
technologies so both the uh the
spiritual or the metaphysical side of
incarnation in that way but also in
terms of the the physical and the
chemistry and the biology and the
technology side of things we actually
are
on behalf of the one moving forward with
less and less diseases and more and more
um successful incarnations with less and
less
deaths at young ages
so medicine is improving
and
what about
to round off
what i would think is
what are the barriers to fourth density
graduation or the earth's awakening
what about nuclear weapons
that's a god-like power that we have
they can't be uninvented
how do you foresee let's say in the next
50 years
human kinds dealing with
these weapons
nice um
so i've i found that the
um interior
and exterior
are in a feedback loop with each other
so as in like consciousness and
physicalism are in a feedback loop with
each other so meaning like if you
if you don't have your basic needs being
met um
and you're working 80 hours a week at
minimum wage that it's going to be
really hard for you to be able to uh
pick up robin and maharshi's who am i
and and but now if your basic needs are
met um
and you do have more freedom um with
your time then you will eventually
deplete yourself of interest in
substances and experiences and
relationships and material possessions
and you'll be like well okay how can i
have eternal peace and happiness well
the answer is
who am i what is i is seeking inward and
so
we have to have both happening
simultaneously so for the answer of
nuclear weapons it would be um
a state of state change like a planetary
constitutionalization
as no nuclear weapons first of all and
so from that consciousness then of we
are one we are depleting ourselves of
all nuclear weapons we will never have
nuclear war from there then
the architectures become
so that there's no nuclear weapons
they're designed the models are designed
so that there's no nuclear weapons but
from a state change at a level of like
the united nations general assembly from
a level of also on the grassroots so
there's no um
there's no rap there's no risings from
within countries that are interested in
especially with the border politics and
border violence with disputes over
religion and land and resources that
there's also no activation of
malevolence from a grassroots level
because people understand at the same
time that they are one with their
neighbors and that they and their
neighbors can actually have tea and have
conversation and have love for each
other because they are looking at
themselves they are not looking at a
separate other
and
this
constitutionalization
do you think it includes pronouncing
basic human needs as human rights
because as far as i'm concerned that
geneva conventions doesn't i mean does
it include
water food and shelter as human rights
i mean
do you think these should be
these should be human rights correct
yeah it's in the sdgs i'm not sure if
it's in the geneva convention but yes it
is in the sdgs uh zero hunger
education for all clean water for all
shelter safety
clean energy
modern cities
yeah these types of things and uh
so yeah with this
constitutionalization
have you heard of
uh chris langan's meta religion idea do
you think that that the religions will
do you think that we can in a
constitutional fashion
unite all religions
under the law of one i love that bro
such a good such a good question such a
good threat for us to play on yeah
because
um when it's so funny when you
um when you look at some of the greatest
that have um that have spoken about what
the nature is
they're all synthesis
they all pulled from all of the
different mystic traditions
they pulled from different retreats
where they sat in silence they sat in
emptiness
they investigated the nature of
impermanence
they
um they took entheogens themselves they
unleashed god within thanks to things
like
dmt psilocybin etc
and and they're all
doing things like you heard me at the
very beginning what did i say i said i
said wadata
tatvamasi i and my father are one i just
pulled from you know
five billions p five billion peoples um
where they look at for their for their
spirituality right and so and so that's
that's the type of thing i think that
we're heading towards um is that et
style consciousness like law of one like
you suggested where you're like looking
at
um
what does earth look like
when it's graduated
um in a couple thousand years where
earth is in fact
all unified all basic needs are met
everybody is prospering everybody's
actualizing their fullest potential
everybody knows the nature of reality um
everybody's basically just designing
better and better ways to maximize
prosperity and flourishing
um
and everybody's playing everybody's
relaxed and um
and so i love that i love that mentality
of like what does it look like and how
do we how do we constitutionalize
ourselves as the future as that and then
reverse engineer okay so what do we need
to do today and in a month and in a year
and in three years in order to be able
to get to that that which is already
done it's also already done like we have
to view it that way at the same time the
enlightened civilization by 2035 is
already done
being and finding our
non-dual to each other
i mean you have stasis and you have
dynamism we're we're
we're driving towards this fourth
density earth
but we're also arriving as it's
happening and
that's where that's where i'm trying to
vibrate the most is is it's so exciting
i mean just the prospect of
international peace or of
i mean in a thousand years this earth
would be breathtaking to to to see but
it's also happening right around us all
the time right now
and
that's i think that beauty is is
something that is easy to it's easy to
either evolve or to
appreciate
but it's it's tricky again to
appreciate as you're evolving like you
were saying with
feeling pain
but also saying that this is actually a
treasure
and that that's not a contradiction
right because to an ordinary person that
that's a complete contra that's that's a
that's a moment of insanity
you could say right but that's defined
in terms of third density egotistical
self-interest
what we're pushing towards is is
planetary love
and so
here's the next question
how are you
in your day-to-day life
seeing
more planetary love more more
more pure love
as opposed to
people ignoring each other on the
streets
well
one thing that arises is here um
in no limit society
we are
[Music]
quite
uh empty of self-interest and so it's
it's really nice when you're just
walking up
and hugging another person out of pure
love
and
and you can both feel that on each other
you can feel it in each other's hearts
there's just a pure love hugging itself
because we are that pure love hugging
itself it's not a human
doing pure love to another human
it's pure love which is the actually
central nature underneath it all
loving itself
through the two individuations
and
and so that i think that's the level
that's the threshold that we should be
aiming at that we should have at our
star um
and
and there are other ways in terms of
there are other scenarios around the
world where it's happening like another
um way of viewing this is um
you know the way that we've transitioned
ourselves to uh like understanding what
indigenous tribes around the world are
talking about regarding um the unity
with all that we are
um or another one is that when
you see um what used to be like a
billion people that didn't have access
to clean water um
that then there would be some sort of a
shift in um in the collective
consciousness to where now it is an sdg
so it is showing up in ways um and
it's not yet fully being actualized
because there's one of the big things
that i've noticed
you know last year i also published a
project called rich patrons in addition
to my first book high level perception
and in that project what i said was that
the reason why we haven't unlocked yet
this
trillions of dollars of surplus that we
actually have across all of the
billionaires on the planet
is because they don't have a trusted way
to put the money
into
solving the actual problems and
challenges and so
a it's not just about funneling the
money into the solutions because then
they still come from a lower density of
consciousness
so what we need to do is we funnel the
money into
consciousness into our scientists our
researchers our academics our
institutions our governments our
economists um the people that are
basically
tuned into the fabric of the collective
on those levels and then as they wake up
more and more
as they understand the nature that's
underlying all phenomena then they
are the ones that then also design the
architectures and policies and models
that then do things like actually funnel
those trillions of dollars into
solutions that are sourceful
source-based solutions
and then it's like you take the
indigenous seventh generation principle
and you actually bring it forth because
the indigenous are thinking 300 years
down the line they're not thinking about
10 years from now
and so that's how you funnel those
trillions of dollars of surplus into the
actualization and you can and you see
that as pure love pure love is when you
shift more and more away from instant
gratification away from self-interest
more and more towards the long-term
planetary prosperity
absolutely
and
i mean
the next question is
that we've covered
a lot of the societal
struggles
and let's let's fast forward say
100 years or 50 years we'll both will
both still be
around
do you think that
there will be more paranormal
experiences on earth that is the more we
realize that there is a spirit world
shall we say
you know there's a time space
if you think of the raw material time
space is dual to space time
and we have mortal worlds right and then
we have the spirit world do you think
that there will be more spirit world
close encounters interactions i mean we
have the disclosure
disclosure is going to be
happening
what do you think about paranormal
experiences that include ets but not
just limited to ets and have you had any
yourself if you want to review nice
yeah i remember when we had rupert
sheldrake on the show we talked about
these different yeah these different
styles of of uh
intelligence that are not
uh common right now um
and
there's an there's an uh an there's an
underlying morphogenesis to everything
um
and
[Music]
a big morphogenetic field which is
basically what it looks like when you
have something that is um
it's evolving
and it's also
uh
[Music]
playing with itself in the evolution and
then it's uh it's all moving to an
attractor of some sort which we could
say is this uh earth awakening
and
through a big possibility space which
has things like uh nukes or no nukes or
bio warfare or no bio warfare
or perverse incentives in the social
media attention economy or not or
shifting to web 3.0 with decentralized
autonomous organizations and nfts
fractional ownership for everybody
and so
it totally feels like all of these new
ways of
communicating between each other are
basically being unlocked right now um
and yeah some of them have to do with
some of these like okay when i'm super
still
and i'm super silent can i actually tune
in to what could be
uh in some sort of an entangled way into
a
uh et
across the cosmos
and um or even just here physically on
earth you could say that can my
consciousness and your consciousness by
just getting nice and slow and silent
can we sort of see the formless nature
of our consciousness with no difference
and with no locational
difference as well and so you can
actually begin sort of like tuning into
even that and then getting more
telepathic and whatnot which is sort of
what's happening here in our field in
the limit society um
and
and so for those that are listening
that's the uh
training free agents for the ignition of
global awakening and you can find the
link in the bio below um
and
yeah bro um
i i would say it's happening in many
different ways that style of of uh next
level comms uh and it's and it's even
visible in these architectures as well
where you're
like even talking about web 3 and like
fractional ownership and um and things
like uh decentralization like
biomimicking what fungal networks are
like in our social contracts like even
that even talking about that is in
itself already a big shift from the
centralized monopolistic uh fabric that
then influences our communication
because it makes us feel like you know
we're victims or that we're separate or
that we're we are in different locations
and so the next level architectures are
going to feed into our consciousness as
the consciousness will feed into
higher density consciousness will feed
into the next generation architectures
which will be much next level
communication
[Music]
next level communication meaning we're
forming
a social memory complex
yes yes and it's good it's good to play
with i've also noticed this i've noticed
that much of my interest in jargon
has also subsided
meaning i still have access to concepts
i still have access to be able to talk
about things like the social memory
complex or smc
but at the same time
i've relaxed more and more of my
conceptual mind
and what's happened is a next level of
emptiness has been able to come through
so more emptiness of self-interest is
actually catalyzed by
the letting go of the conceptual mind
and then
the that that emptiness can actually
still access concepts as it needs in
service to others
as as needed exactly yes exactly rather
than leading the way rather than trying
to accumulate an amass and become
superior
because that's a tendency that that the
mind
has
ascend to the top and everything else
is now at the bottom of a hierarchy um
but so now that you're relaxing more
how do you find your thoughts moving
from from data i mean
when you're just walking around the room
right
are you
still are you still thinking of yourself
as internally
thinking or are you
externally projecting your thoughts or
is it still a feedback or how how is it
for you day-to-day
every day is basically a liberation of
the center
more and more of a liberation of the
center
so
every day is becoming more and more
centerless
and it's catching
the formation of self faster and faster
and the dissolving of the
cell faster and faster um
and
it's yeah it's just more and more like
dissolving into the fabric of divine
love
um
yeah and then there's like words just
escape and then just words fall away
words fall away or rather speaking
becomes a little more like singing
or playing yeah rather than just
information exchange
nice
yes like
you enjoy the the tone the pace
the faces facial expressions
that's what it becomes and then at a
certain point you just start get looking
at each other and then
telepathy begins
[Laughter]
yep
how about how about you with uh with
waking up and also with um how you've
shifted um given that because it sounds
like you were just describing it a bit
and it sounded really nice and
interesting
[Laughter]
well it might
my background's a little bit
unconventional maybe because
i remember one of my first
thoughts being
the law of one
and
i mean
i was very fortunate as a child both my
parents were extremely loving i had an
extremely loving family
uh sister who's a year and a half
younger
who was my best friend growing up
i had no
want i had no
my basic needs were satisfied um so i
didn't have to worry about
trauma
and it it that
allowed
a sort of opening
i would actually look at the sun i
wanted to look at the sun even though i
knew it hurt your eyes
and i would look right at it and i would
feel good eventually i would just close
my eyes while i looked at it and uh
i remember um
that
i would just feel this
closeness because i would
feel the heat
inside of my organs and i thought well
the sun has to be millions of miles away
so what's this connection
and then i would look at the earth and i
would think of myself as falling right
through
and then remember you know thinking of
these celestial connections and then
looking beyond and then looking at the
stars and what
what's all that out there
and somehow
you know i i realized that i had no
understanding
of a star or the sun or even of the
earth
i realized i was completely ignorant of
how anything worked the only thing i
knew was that i existed
and because of that
i guess i deduced that
existence has to just be one thing or
one object nice and
and from that i just started looking at
my parents
and it's not i mean at the time it was
it was naive and i guess this does
happen in developmental psychology where
you just identify everything as yourself
and so i was just looking at myself and
my parents and at the room and at trees
and things and i would just
identify myself as them and say well
that's me and whatever they're doing i'm
doing and
then as i grew up i started to realize
though that i did have an ego
and that i did have this local identity
that wanted to express itself and
and sometimes in not so
friendly ways
and i reflected on
any
toxicity or any chronic negativity that
i experienced towards myself or others
and i started to realize
the law of one again so basically i
forgot about the law of one through my
teens
i i ever you know from four years old up
until about 13
it was all about the law of one
and everything was part of me and and
basically it was it was a joy-filled
childhood and and i that to that extent
it might be unconventional
but um then i sort of forgot for another
13 years
that everything is one because i was
dealing so intensely with other people
and so i felt
this dualism very very chronically for a
while and you know i'd say in the last
two years
i remembered
that the law of one is
the one truth and i began to unite with
people and i mean i you know i still
retain my that's the thing
i still retain my personality
in a sense
more and more i'm trying to access a
magical personality that doesn't cling
to
this local body but just
spherically spreads this body wherever
it contacts like i was like
when i was a kid
but not
in a naive way anymore
not just identifying myself blindly with
other people rather discerning
because for a long time
it's easy to just judge
it's easy to just condemn and to see
something negative and say well that's
just pure idiocy
right or to or to condemn yourself
but i realize that you can discern
without condemning you can just open
your heart and have mercy towards
whatever you're seeing and compassion
and then the spectrum
goes from positivity to negativity
to joy and compassion
so whenever something negative is
happening
i queue up to either become
compassionate
or merciful whether to myself or to
somebody else and
if something bad isn't happening then
we're just on the on the way to joy
and so
that's my i guess my
i've tried to convert the positive
negative duality into a non-dual
spectrum
where
negativities
are basically just
challenges to the positive emotion
basically challenges the positive
emotion to extend itself into the
negative event
and thereby become magical
yeah or metaphysical yes yes and that
that's that's that's
i have to do that because i'm in a
classroom with 30 kids who are 13 and
whoever forgetting
the law of one although i will say that
they do
seem pre-incarnationally primed to force
density love
much more than
than even i was as a kid and i had a
very fortunate childhood yeah so
that's a big shift that i'm noticing
nice
yeah i loved when you were sharing this
focus on both the the positivity and
then also just existence itself
and then also the seeing how
even the kids that you're teaching today
in the school
that they have a greater um
in a sense they it's a
there's an entanglement that's happening
with them where they have a greater
access to the unity that everything is
but they also at the same time have a
greater tendency to possibly get very
distracted um by uh the what's what's
also evolved and so
um
[Music]
you can get more self-absorbed uh lower
case s self
um
yeah by the modern technologies as you
can also seek truth faster and more
efficiently
and uh and liberate yourself from
illusion faster so it's it's really
interesting it's an entanglement that
that is uh that's happening there um
beautiful beautiful bro
yeah there is there there definitely is
an entanglement between technological
and metaphysical evolution i mean
each kid
we have to confiscate the phones at the
beginning of the day because
it would be impossible to teach if they
had their phone in their pocket
but
the phone is also allowing for ex
highly increased communication another
weird thing that i've noticed is that
people are a lot more open with their
romances with their
crushes back when i was a you know 10 20
15 years ago it was a secret or it was a
big deal now it's all out in the open
and so that's there's a little subtle
things that i'm noticing that
there there's much more openness
i ask them questions like
does
war over land
make sense
and
war no longer makes sense to them
before as a kid
yeah yeah i mean
i set up the class so that
we're running a fourth density class i
have to remember my that
i love that you're like i'm running a
fourth density class i love that i love
how like our teachers are starting to
like say that that's so cool yeah
i'm running a class based on
non-separation based on unity that's so
cool bro i love that and i noticed
strange correlations
talking about entanglement there's
strange correlations if i show up
in the morning in a bad mood students
are much more chaotic and they they
behave in i mean or and towards me i'm
not so when i approach a student
and let's say i'm in a bad mood they can
already sense it they can already see it
on me and they're immediately going to
shell up
whereas if i simply
soften my heart and i'm like well you
know a lot of these kids
are
coming from who knows i mean i do know
their housing situation a lot of them
are struggling in many ways when it
comes to base i mean the school has
gives them breakfast and lunch
a lot of them
you know struggle for basic needs at
home they struggle in many ways and yet
and yet they have this openness this
purity to them they open up to their to
their teacher very easily they're
excited to come to school even though
you know it's a fourth density classroom
but we're also working on paper
and we're working and i i'm trying to
elevate them and see the your voice your
your actual voice is what we're working
on your mind and your spirit and you
know ultimately if you're not feeling
happy in this classroom if you're not
enjoying yourself in some way
then i'm actually harming you
and i'd i prefer not to do that and so
when
when they get out of hand
and when i i always say things like well
you're actually forcing me
to lower my consciousness right now
you're forcing me to treat you
like you're younger and like you don't
understand how to be respectful etc etc
but
if we can actually elevate our own
consciousness and i i speak this way
because they get it you know if we
elevate our own consciousness to
a a loving state then maybe we can
actually have an enjoyable classroom and
we don't have to suffer throughout the
day
nice you talk about everything in
consciousness in class that's so cool i
have to i have to because you have 30
kids who want to talk to each other
about things that have nothing to do
with social studies
so
there's two ways of going about it you
either yell at them and tell everybody
to shut up
okay or you get their attention in some
way but getting their attention
either implies you tell them a story or
something it usually doesn't have to do
with school
right so sometimes i'll do that
sometimes it's story time and they get
to hear about some kind of paranormal
experience i've had or something or
other but it's all meant to
get them
to enjoy the day because i suffered
through the day i did not like school at
all i thought it was a prison and
i didn't want to be there
and i thought i would learn better if i
just walked around outside
but
you know
people thought it was something that had
to be done so
if you would ask me are you going to be
a teacher when i was a kid i would have
i would have shaken my head and probably
scoffed
but i then then i realized that
you know even though the school
structures that we have today like the
length of the day the division of
subjects how many kids are in a single
class
things like that
even how the subjects are taught all
these things have to be updated in terms
of fourth density but i can still run a
fourth density classroom
on the existing structures
and that's what yeah that's the shift
that's the shift that's that's the shift
you know it sometimes it feels like an
app like a tooth abscess because you
know the the old structures can really
weigh you down yeah i mean the school
day the they're they're in class from 8
30 to 4 30
and the there's a lot of
serious time
they have one hour approximately of
lunch and recess combined out of like
six or seven
of serious time so in my class
it's fun time
okay it's social studies we're studying
how to socialize
i always make i make little jokes like
that um
yeah how does fourth density socialize
it's so cute exactly
yeah
no
so it that's that's a a personal
challenge that uh that i'm experiencing
it's it's very fun
um and that's how i get to
instantiate fourth density in the
day-to-day
but i'm sure straight implementation i
love that though because that's what
it's all about because
it's um
it's so much about anchoring
the realizations into the fabric of
existence and so it's weaving it's the
tantric realization of weaving what
you've discovered about the underlying
oneness into the world and you do that
yeah
through the ways that we've been talking
about on the show it's it's so good and
it's so good hearing that um this i've
never heard that before fourth density
classroom and that's starting to like
really it's ringing right here it's so
sweet and it feels so good um feeling
you and feeling the kids like
coming from a place of love coming from
a place of oneness in the classroom
itself um
so good
yeah it's a joy man it's a joy and
i think it's a testament to
the shift that's happening because
a lot of them like i said they're so
open that they share traumatic
experience with me experiences with me
that
would
totally have broken me if i had
if i'd experienced that
but instead
you know they just double down and say
well that just means that family has to
be flexible or your you know a friend
can be
just as can express just as much love to
you as a parent if necessary
and to me
they're more and more seeing that the
earth family is what we're shifting
towards and that we can't just have
these little nuclear islands
cool um
so cool they i mean they
learn about they learn about the
distinction between the communal family
and the nuclear family and they all
think about how we have to unite them
because they know that we can't have a
communal family in the standard
indigenous sense the society is too big
we have too much complexity but at the
same time we can't have all this closure
because because then you only care about
your family
and i i'll ask them a question like
um
should you
care about someone you have no idea
about
or rather should you care about a
stranger
a pure stranger
and they all ask well what did the
stranger do
but then the question is well who cares
right
some one kid always raises that question
they could have done something terrible
but
they're still a person
and they still deserve some kind of
mercy
and then the rest of the class starts to
realize oh yeah well even if they did
something terrible the the likelihood is
that they didn't the likelihood is that
they're just someone who's out there
you know in some
field
right probably struggling for basic
needs and they think
it makes no sense to not think of the
planet as some kind of mega family
which is something that
would be non-intuitive
for a lot of
people
it's it's but that's the thing it's in
it's intuitive to them
they don't have an issue understanding
these things they don't have an issue
understanding that war is incoherent
these things don't
uh
confuse them they just have a clear
answer
and that's why uh
i'm so excited about the coming years
because even when
even in this tells me that even in 10
years
i mean our the the density
of of our of our consciousness is going
to be much higher
it's so exciting with the little ones i
love it war is incoherent and they're
seven and they're seventh graders
they're you know they're they're they're
young they're 12 13 year old kids
they're but
they're and they're they're experiencing
adolescence
and that is
the shift in itself and yet and and yet
they understand that bullying of all
forms is
undesirable from everybody's perspective
they these things that that were kind of
implicit
15 20 years ago even are now just
completely intuitive and explicit
so that's so good fourth density is here
yeah why would i why would i create the
traumas like why would i call why would
i catalyze trauma that's such a good
question for kids to ask themselves
so good yeah
exactly and their answer is it's so
unnecessary i mean if you're going to do
something negative
right it has to be at least necessary
that this is another conversation that
always comes up with them because
learning about early american history
they're learning about a lot of trauma
right they're learning about genocide
and slavery and how people
survived slavery how does somebody not
commit suicide is a question that they
come up with
when it comes to slavery
and
of course then we shift the attention to
well they had families on the many
talking about american slavery they had
families and how is it that family love
can be so strong
that you would prefer to stay on the
plantation with your family
then
basically
commit suicide or try to escape which is
equivalent to suicide
and
you know so family love
it it doesn't fourth density doesn't
mean that you lose your family you know
you mean but it does mean that you have
to open your heart to people you have no
clue about
and
i think that's a very beautiful thing
and i mean here's here's a question did
did you enjoy school i mean
are you
what was your school experience like
yeah and can i also ask for the audience
would you
mind um sharing with us a general like
location um of where your school is oh
yeah new york city
okay cool and then is it um
is it a it's a public school
it's a public charter it has it drives
some funding
yeah yeah
okay
nice
um
and you said it's eighth grade right
thirteen years it's middle school
seventh grade
right now but yeah middle school sixth
through eighth
nice
yeah
sweet
wow
dude it's so exciting um i was
mentioning to you that one of my one of
my best friends um growing up uh greg
harner he also um
is social studies teaching and i think
that he would love to
hear this and because he and so many
other teachers that are like you
basically that are in a sense it's like
30 like 30 year old teachers that are
like um
uh like that are
seeing the earth slowly shifting into a
more awakened state and now it's like
well
also my kids
see that war is
in uh incoherent they my kids see earth
as a mega family and it's great because
you as you wake up you catalyze that in
the classroom because you can't show up
with your state of being being off
because if you show up that way it gets
reflected to you by the kids and so it's
great so you show up um more and more
consistently from that unity and then
you get to catalyze great questions for
them to like basically turn inward and
be like uh no i do care about some
stranger that i don't know
and
that's so good um for me school was
fantastic um it
um
it
it was a great
example of me being able to like
actualize my intelligence um because you
know my my family also um put in a lot
into me being
like
very agile like very polymathic i'm very
intelligent my mind my mind is very
sharp i distilled the essences of a lot
of different fields um up until i was
like 18 years old and then that totally
played a huge role into
the last 10 years of my life
and so
um
now now i would say that the thing that
did happen when i was in school that i
would like to shift a bit was
um
there was not so much of a focus on
consciousness there was not so much of a
focus on what metaphysics the nature of
reality there wasn't a big focus on on
unity and oneness and um the planetary
architectures to meet basic needs and
this type of stuff and so i actually
have interviewed several people on the
show from different schools that are
that are either like founders of those
schools or that they run those schools
and that
typically what the answers are is things
like it's built into our curriculum now
like consciousness oneness unity the
sdgs project-based learning um this is
all built into our curriculum now and
it's and that's that lights me up every
time i hear that type of stuff so
that's uh
i'm really grateful to all my teachers i
love my teachers with all my heart um
and i whenever i go back to my hometown
i usually stop at my elementary school
my middle school and my high school and
i go and i check in and i give them so
much love um
because
uh you know having a kid show up
that like took your class 20 years ago
or 15 years ago or 10 years ago and to
have them come back and just be super
grateful um is like
for them it's like oh my gosh and like
wow you also host this show where you
talk to people about you know maximizing
human potential and stuff and so they
get really excited they're like i taught
someone that is now doing this on behalf
of the world and it's um
it's really good it's really good to
to have to have a heart-to-heart
relationship so close and so loving with
with your teachers and so hopefully
that's another thing for yeah for you
and your students now is like dude
they're that they in like five years 10
years 15 years are also going to be
doing great things around the world and
they're going to be like oh my gosh
bernard this is what i'm doing
we're teaching you
yeah
yeah and that's that's the long-term
catalyst that's catalysis right that
that you are embodying and i love that i
mean
i would say that
the
transition to fourth density education
is still very very in its very very
beginning stages
um we're doing well in encoding fourth
density ideas in third density curricula
but the curricula themselves remain
third density in the sense that
we're still learning about
science math social studies and ela all
in division
and those divisions technically
probably don't hold in fourth density in
the way we think but
i have
my challenge is to
transitionally
update
the
the education in my own curriculum which
i construct and
the
education system itself i mean
in time i will i will come out with a
little blueprint for what a fourth
density
school could look like
in its entirety i would love to stay
tuned for that yeah yeah i would love to
create with you on that it's so exciting
um
and also my other yeah my other friends
that either are teachers or that have
founded these different charters and
schools i would love for um for a deeper
collaboration there um also onorag is
doing a lot of work in that space which
is super cool um
andy bittner is too
so it's i'm so excited about that i'm so
excited that you're passionate about
this because like
oh this is so this is so instrumental
because we're not just gonna overnight
shift everybody out of 3d schools so the
so the so one of the best ways is to
basically bring 4d into
the seeds in and then water them in the
3d until they shift more and more into
40. um
so good and meanwhile also be building
completely different um schools that
kids can go to like for example awakened
parents like
you me we're not yet
i assume you're not right
but yeah
and like and like many of the people in
like no limit society that are young
like under 30 like don't have kids and
so like eventually when they do have
kids dude they're not gonna put their
kids through any 3d [ __ ] so that means
that they're going to be looking for a
4d school curricula style and so this is
um it's going to be a big also um
success because there's going to be a
lot of demand for it
yeah and it's going to look very
different right i mean the the content
that they'll be learning the way they'll
be learning it very very different um i
i'm personally
extremely excited about that's the thing
i'm most excited about right now is the
development of
40 schools
i love that bro gosh that's so exciting
for me
cool that's great i love i love actually
adding that as like a tag to our
relationship is 40 schools so good bro
yeah i mean it i should have i should
have a blueprint in the next year for
what one would look like and
how
the curriculum will change
how the day to day will change the whole
thing has to be formulated but
i have it fully formed i just have to
write it out it's a little bit tricky to
get some free time these days but
i'll i'll put it down soon and we can
talk about it i love it yeah we could do
another show on 40 schools also that's
so good bro um also i would i would love
to
i would love to say um
to the audience as well because we'll
have the law of one
dot info we'll have that link in the bio
for you guys to check out but generally
what we're talking about when we're
talking about densities is we're talking
about densities of consciousness and
that means um the amount of love
light awareness so awareness love and
light that is present in the mind body
spirit complex so
um meaning in each person in a simple
way in each person
in this mirror is the chakras so the
seven chakras is mirrored
same thing with the colors of the
rainbow or the c d e f g a b the musical
octave um
that generally uh the shift is happening
from the third density which you could
say as like a very
matrix style uh fabric um of
centralization and of separation that
type of thing um to where your fourth
density is the heart chakra so you're
shifting up into this unity
awareness love light
and
then that is what we're talking about in
terms of implementing into the school is
that style of shift in this big timeline
of
13.8 billion years of evolution as i
said that each one of these little earth
simulators goes on its little
evolution in the densities of
consciousness and so this is where we're
at right now on this planet earth
simulator and that we have this
opportunity to go directly into
the um
the education of what children are
inputting every single day into their
consciousness and then to create
catalysts through what they're inputting
so that they get
more flavors of unity and oneness and
awakening
non-separation full actualization at
younger ages so yeah i just wanted to
briefly also clarify for people
yeah i mean the densities are
difficult to understand in our current
context because they're more general
than dimensions
but
we're talking about right densities of
consciousness and students understand
that consciousness is the name of the
game
and you know they they no longer are
worried about third density
imperatives as much
they realize that those are
transitional
um
so you know i think
i speak
rather freely with students i i don't
sugarcoat why they're there i
don't actually pretend that the school
that i'm in even though it allows me all
this freedom
that any third density school
is
going to allow you to fully enjoy your
day it is still very difficult to move
through a school day
um
in the existing structures
and being a little vague right now but
that's because you know this is still
introductory but i mean in terms of how
long the classes are and things like
that um
it's it's actually easy
to resist
a fourth density school because it's
going to appear at first that kids
aren't going to be learning anything
right because we understand school as
this transmission of information like
you have a stimulance response machine a
bunch of students or stimulus response
machines and then you just feed them
input
as the teacher
that that model
is what is going to be replaced as this
co-creative model that that we could
talk about in the future but
yeah man that's
it's very very nice
very nice
so i think uh
i think one more question then
uh before we close
i love you
[Laughter]
do you do you actively think of
your own body
as absorbing
force density light more and more every
day
that's a cool question
yeah i mean are you recep we're opening
denser
yeah opening our aperture for sure yeah
um less and less uh less and less
density of
uh lowercase s self right so
um
yeah and so then as um
as the density of conditioning and the
density of separation and contraction
decrease
um the opening of the aperture to light
and love
increases and freedom increases
and it's
one infinite creator intelligence
gets to be the daily
um
moment-to-moment guidance and
and inspiration
and
it feels so good and it feels way
more decentralized and way less
contracted way more centerless
way more like you said also it's like a
dance and a play in communication and
yeah
absolutely man i mean you're very you're
very cells
okay you're the the new cells that are
being generated in your body when you're
experiencing loving thoughts or loving
feelings
those are fourth density cells in a
sense maybe we can talk about that in
the future conversation
yeah
i mean oh
yeah 4d cells that's cool 40 cells man
whoa
i love this yeah
that's such a good point
that's such a good point because
um
even like in biology it can really
relate well with this because
um
we do know we do know very clearly that
um
from like this cambrian explosion era
until now from even a biogenesis intel
cambrian explosion until now it's a very
clear like lineage of cellular evolution
and then even up until now these like 30
trillion celled human vehicles
that it's so cool because they have not
stopped
they're continuing to evolve and so
that's why you have the [ __ ] cerebral
cortex and that you have this prefrontal
cortex and that you have all of this
like next level next generation
also in technology that's coming out
with what we're feeling into with ar vr
neurotech biotech all these different
fields um and you know doing that with a
lot of ethics and doing that with a lot
of morality and a lot of um future
presence around oneness and unity so
there's no malevolence that can like
squeak in there um but then that that
then feeds back into yeah the cellular
evolution and i love that yeah four d
cells like literally the cells
themselves
being infused more and more with love
light and i actually now that you say
that i feel that more and more as my
aperture
because it feels like you're dancing the
one infinite creator um
instead of um
it the the contracted energy feels like
your cells are more like third density
that's such a interesting way to to put
it your state your state state of being
is from a fourth density cellular
intelligence that's so cool
yeah the cell you think of the cells of
having more connections with other cells
behaving more like like actual networks
than cells single cells right you think
of third density cell i mean third
density is based on cells but then
fourth density right you start getting
into systemic action
which is what's which is
so
we maybe this is a can of worms we'll
talk about it in a future
episode but you can give us a little bit
more you can give us a little more
because keep going okay
raw raw talks about the
creation of what they called green core
particles so green has to do with the
fourth chakra which is 4d and so they
used this metaphorical language but what
they were saying was that the earth's
environment is being more becoming more
conducive to the production and
acceptance
right
of
shall we say 4d photons from the sun and
those 40 photons can be accepted by
human cells or other third you could
argue that certain animals
exhibit third density consciousness like
i mean if you if you have a dog or a cat
or any i mean really any animal but
anyway you these these cells can accept
40 photons and those 40 photons can
activate more internal connections with
other cells and that basically creates
systemic action as opposed to individual
cell action individual cell action is
what allows for cancer and other
degenerations to occur because those
cells basically
lose track of their connections with
other cells when a cell thinks of its of
itself as more of a system
than an individual
just like a human right if a human
thinks of itself as more of a system
than an individual little island
you see what i'm saying so the 4d cell
thing
and by that very nature the cell gains
because 4d
you could i mean
the dimensions of space okay you got the
dimensions of space but also also
there's dimensions of time right you
have past present and future but in but
in 4d
you get an entire past life
or pre-programming in terms of which all
your your body is going to evolve i mean
the the parameters of your body are set
before the lifetime i mean they're very
wide obviously but you have the whole i
mean think of it as like carving your
own possibility space right
the cells have their own carving of
their own possibility space but what
we're able to do now these 40 photons
the more we think these loving thoughts
we're able to activate
locked regions of our dna right what
crispr and things like that can do we
can do that endogenously through
4d thoughts and feelings and
those are the that's that's what i can
say for now that your cells are
basically accepting more levels of
processing
so good bro
maybe we can we can
we can talk whenever whenever you want
man i actually have to go
but um perfect it's uh it's amazing
exchanging energy with you yeah you too
i i love um 40 schools 40 cells um and
just more about earth's awakening and
earth shift
and the curricula um as well yes schools
so yeah bernard this is beautiful my
brother this is uh the beginning of a
beautiful friendship and i'm so so
excited
thank you so so much thank you thank you
thank you
yeah super cool um conversation
and um
oh yeah also for everybody um
uh love you guys thank you for tuning in
everyone thank you
uh thank you we would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode drop us a comment
also um like the video it helps
algorithm uh subscribe to the channel if
you haven't yet also share this
conversation with bernard to your
friends
that are interested in nurse awakening
this will generate some great catalysts
for them
and also check out the link in the bio
below
we have bernard's youtube channel so go
and subscribe to that like his videos
check out his content as well share it
with other people if you find it to be
resonant he does a great job over there
and
[Music]
uh that's yeah that's all also yeah love
one link is in the bio to check out and
also is
the no limit society what we're building
here so um infinite love to you guys
also what is i and high level perception
the books um that i wrote will be there
um love you guys so much bernard any
other um thoughts
remember the law of one everything you
look at is technically
isomorphic to you
that's it
amen amen i'll end the stream and then
um you and i will stay in for just a
minute okay everyone bye